before I talk about some of the
interesting stuff with parallelization
all that let's let's first talk about
like the basics we talked to indentation
right so this thing looks like python
it's sexy and beautiful like python as
we mentioned uh is it a typed language
so what's the role of types yeah good
question so python has types it has
strings as integers it has dictionaries
and like all that stuff but they all
live at runtime
right and so because all those types
look at runtime in Python you never you
don't have to spell them python also has
like this whole typing thing going on
now and a lot of people use it yeah I'm
not talking about that that's that's
kind of a different thing we can go back
to that if you want but but typically
the um
you know you just say I take I have a
death and my deaf takes two parameters
I'm gonna call them A and B and I don't
have to write a type okay so that
is great but what that does is that
forces what's called a consistent
representation so these things have to
be a pointer to an object with the
object header and they all have to look
the same and then when you dispatch a
method you go through all the same
different paths no matter what the the
receiver whatever that type is so what
Mojo does is it allows you to have more
than one kind of type and so what it
does is allows you to say okay cool I
have I have an object an object's behave
like python does and so it's fully
Dynamic and that's all great and for
many things classes like that's all very
powerful and very important
but if you want to say hey it's an
integer and it's 32 bits or 64 bits or
whatever it is or it's a floating point
value
at six four bits well then the compiler
can take that and it can use that to do
way better optimization it turns out
again getting rid of the interactions
that's huge means you can get better
code completion because you have
um because compiler knows what the type
is and so knows what operations work on
it and so that's actually pretty huge
and so what Mojo does allows you to
progressively adopt types into your
program so you can start again it's
compatible with python and so then you
can add however many types you want
wherever you want them and if you don't
want to deal with it you don't have to
deal with it right and so one of one of
you know our opinions on this is It's
not that types are the right thing or
the wrong thing
it's a very useful thing
I wish it was kind of optional it's not
strict typing like you don't have to
specify a type exactly
okay so it's starting from the thing
that Python's kind of reaching towards
right now with trying to inject types
into it yeah with a very different
approach but yes yes what's the
different approach I'm actually one of
the people
that have not been using types very much
in Python okay why did you say
it's just well because I I know the
importance it's like adults use strict
typing and so I I refuse to grow up in
that sense it's a it's a kind of
rebellion but I I just know that um
it probably reduces the amount of Errors
even just for forget about performance
improvements it probably reduces errors
of when you do strict typing yeah so I
mean I think it's interesting if you
look at that right and the reason I'm
giving a hard time yeah is that that
there's this this cultural norm this
pressure this like there has to be a
right way to do things like you know
only grown-ups only do it one way and if
you don't do that you should feel bad
yes right like some people feel like
Python's a guilty pleasure or something
and that's like when it gets serious I
need to go rewrite it right yeah exactly
well I mean cool I understand history
and I understand kind of where this
comes from but I don't think it has to
be a guilty pleasure yeah right so if
you look at that you say why do you have
to rewrite it well you have to rewrite
it to deploy well why do you want to
deploy well you care about performance
you care about perfect ability or you
want you know a tiny thing on the server
that has no dependencies or you know you
have objectives you're trying to attain
so what if python can achieve those
objectives
so if you want types well maybe you want
types because you want to make sure
you're passing the right thing sure you
can add a type if you don't care you're
protyping some stuff you're hacking some
things out you're like pulling some Ram
good off the internet it should just
work right and you shouldn't be like
pressured you shouldn't feel bad about
doing the right thing or the thing that
feels good now if you're in a team right
you're working at some massive internet
company and you have 400 million lines
of python code well they they may have a
house rule that you use types yeah right
because it makes it easier for different
humans to talk to each other and
understand what's going on and bugs at
scale right and so there are lots of
good reasons why you might want to use
types but that doesn't mean that
everybody should use them all the time
right so what Mojo does is it says cool
well allow people to use types and if
you use types you get nice things out of
it right you get better performance and
things like this right but Mojo is a
full compatible superset of python
and so that means it has to work without
types it has to support all the dynamic
things I support all the packages that
support uh for comprehension list
comprehensions and things like this
right and so that that that starting
point I think is really important and I
think that
again you can look at why I care so much
about this and there's many different
aspects of that one of which is the
world went through a very challenging
migration from python 2 to python 3.
right yes this migration took many years
and it was very painful for many teams
right and there's a lot of a lot of
things that went on in that
um I'm not an expert in all the details
and I honestly don't want to be I don't
want the world to have to go through
that yeah right and you know people can
ignore Mojo and if it's not their thing
that's that's cool but if they want to
use Mojo I don't want them to have to
rewrite all their code yeah I mean just
look at the superset part is
there's just I mean there's so much
bullying stuff here that definitely is
is incredible
um we'll talk about that yeah first of
all how's the typing implemented
differently
in uh in python versus uh Mojo So this
heterogeneous flexibility you said is
definitely implemented yeah so I'm not a
full expert in the whole backstory and
types in Python so I'll give you I'll
give you that I can give you my
understanding
um my understanding is basically like
many Dynamic languages the ecosystem
went through a phase where people went
from writing scripts to write on a large
scale huge code bases in Python and at
scale it kind of helps have types yeah
people want to be able to reason about
interfaces what what do you expect a
string or an intro like what these basic
things right and so what the python
Community started doing is it started
saying okay let's have tools on the side
Checker tools right the go and like
enforce some variants check for bugs try
to identify things these are called
Static analysis tools generally and so
these tools run over your code and try
to look for bugs what ended up happening
is there's so many of these things so
many different weird patterns and
different approaches on specifying the
types and different things going on that
the python Community realize and
recognize hey hey there's the thing here
and so what they started to do is they
started to standardize the Syntax for
adding types to python now one of the
challenges that they had is that they're
coming from kind of this fragmented
world where there's lots of different
tools they have different trade-offs and
interpretations and the types mean
different things and so if you look at
types in Python according to the python
spec
the types are ignored
right so according to python spec you
can write pretty much anything in in a
tight position okay and um
you can technically you can write any
expression okay now
that's beautiful because you can extend
it you can do cool things you can build
your own tools you can build your own
house linter or something like that
right but it's also a problem because
any existing Python program may be using
different tools and they have different
interpretations and so if you adopt
somebody's package into your ecosystem
try to run the tool you prefer it may
throw out tons of weird errors and
warnings and problems just because it's
incompatible with how these things work
also because they're added late and
they're not checked by the python
interpreter it's always kind of more of
a hint than it is a requirement also the
C python implementation can't use them
for performance and so it's really
that's a big one right so you can
utilize the for the compilation for the
just in time compilation okay exactly
and this this all comes back to the
design principle if it's it's kind of
they're kind of hints they're kind of
the definition is a little bit murky
it's unclear exactly the interpretation
in a bunch of cases and so because of
that you can't actually even if you want
to it's really difficult to use them to
say like it is going to be an INT and if
it's not it's a problem right a lot of
go to break if you did that so so in
Mojo right so you can still use those
kind of type annotations it's fine but
in Mojo if you declare a type and you
use it then it means it is going to be
that type and the compiler helps you
check that and force it and it's safe
um and it's not it's not a like best
effort kind of a thing so if you try to
shovel string type thing into a integer
you get an error from the compiler
compile time
nice okay what kind of basic types are
there yeah so uh Mojo is
um pretty hardcore in terms of what it
tries to do in the language which is the
philosophy there is that we
um
again if you if you look at python right
Python's a beautiful language because
it's so extensible right and so all of
the different things in Python like for
loops and plus and like all these things
can be accessed through these Under
Armor methods okay so you have to say
okay if I make something that is super
fast I can go all the way down to the
metal why do I need to have integers
built into the language
and so what Mojo does it says okay well
we can have this notion of structs so we
have classes in Python now you can have
structs classes are Dynamic structs are
static cool we can get high performance
we can write C plus plus kind of code
with structs if you want these things
mix and work beautifully together but
what that means is that you can go and
Implement strings and ins and floats and
arrays and all that kind of stuff in the
language
right and so that's really cool because
you know to me is a ideal idealizing
compile compiler language type of person
what I want to do is I want to get magic
out of the compiler and put in the
libraries because if somebody can you
know if we can build an integer that's
beautiful and it has an amazing API it
does all the things you'd expect an
Editor to do
we don't like it maybe you want a big
integer maybe you want to like sideways
integer I don't know like what what all
the space of integers are um then uh
then you can do that and it's not a
second class citizen
and so if you look at certain other
languages like C plus plus one I also
love and use a lot um
into hard code in the language
but complex is not and so isn't it kind
of weird that you know you have this STD
complex class but you have int and
complex tries to look like a natural
numeric type and things like this but
integers and floating Point have these
like special promotion rules and other
things like that that are magic and
they're hacked into the compiler and
because of that you can't actually make
something that works like the built-in
types is there something provided as a
standard because uh you know because
it's AI first
you know numerical types are so
important here so is there something
like a nice standard implementation of
integer influence yeah so so we're still
building all that stuff out so we
provide interest and floats and all that
kind of stuff we also provide like
buffers and sensors and things like that
that you'd expect in an ml context
honestly we need to keep designing and
redesigning and working with the
community to build that out and make
that better that's not our strength
right now
give us six months or a year and I think
it'll be way better but um but the power
of putting in the library means we can
have teams of experts that aren't
compiler Engineers that can help us
design and refine and drive this forward
so uh one of the exciting things we
should mention here is that this is uh
this is new and fresh this cake is
unbaked
it's almost baked you can tell it's
delicious
but it's not fully ready to be consumed
yep that's very fair it is very useful
but it's very useful if you're a super
low level programmer right now and what
we're doing is we're working our way up
the stack and so the way I would look at
Mojo today in May and 2023
um is that it's like a 0.1
so I think that you know a year from now
it's gonna be way more interesting to a
variety of people but what we're doing
is we're we decided to release it early
so that people can get access to it and
play with them we can build it with the
community we um have a big road map
fully published being transparent about
this and a lot of people are involved in
this stuff and so what we're doing is
we're really optimizing for building
this thing the right way and building it
the right way is kind of interesting
working with the community because
everybody wants it yesterday
and so it's sometimes it's kind of you
know there's some Dynamics there but
yeah I think it's the right thing so
there's a Discord also so the Dynamics
is pretty interesting sometimes the
community probably can be very chaotic
and uh introduce a lot of stress Guido
famously quit over the stress of the
walrus operator I mean yeah you know it
broke
maybe
exactly and so like it could be very
stressful to develop but can you just
add tangent upon a tangent is it
stressful to to uh
to work through the design of various
features here given that the community
is so richly involved well so um so I've
been doing open development and
Community stuff for decades now somehow
this has happened to me
um so I've I've learned some tricks but
the the thing that always gets me is I
want to make people happy right and so
this is this is maybe not all people all
happy all the time but generally I want
I want people to be happy right and so
the challenge is that again we're
tapping into some long
some deep-seated long tensions and
pressures both in the python world but
also in the AI world and the hardware
world and things like this and so people
just want us to move faster right and so
again our decision was let's release
this early let's get people used to it
or access to it and play with it and
like let's let's build in the open which
we could have you know had the the
language monk sitting in the Cloister up
on the hilltop like beavering away
trying to build something but in my
experience you get something that's way
better if you work with the community
right uh and so yes it can be
frustrating can be challenging for lots
of people involved and you know if you I
mean if you mention our Discord we have
over 10 000 people on the Discord 11 000
people or something keep in mind we
released Mojo like two weeks ago yeah so
um it's very active so it's very cool
um but what that means is that um you
know 10 11 000 people all will want
something different right and so what
we've done is we've tried to say okay
cool here's our roadmap here here and
the roadmap isn't completely arbitrary
it's based on here's the logical order
in which to build these features or add
add these capabilities and things like
that and what we've done is we've spun
really fast on like bug fixes and so we
actually have very few bugs which is
cool I mean actually for a project in
the state but then what we're doing is
we're dropping in features very
deliberately I mean this is fun to watch
because you got the two
gigantic communities of like Hardware
like systems engineers and then you have
the machine learning python people that
are like higher level yeah and it's just
two like four like Army like uh they've
been at War yeah they've been at War
right and so so here's the Tolkien novel
or something okay so here's the test
again like it's it's super funny for for
something that's only been out for two
weeks right people are so impatient
right but okay cool let's fast forward a
year
like in a year's time Mojo will be
actually quite amazing and solve tons of
problems would be very good
um people still have these problems
right and so you you look at this you
say and the way I look at this at least
is to say okay well we're solving big
long-standing problems
to me I again working on many different
problems I want to make sure we do it
right
there's like a responsibility you feel
because if you mess it up right there's
very few opportunities to do projects
like this and have them really have
impact on the world if we do it right
then maybe we can take those feuding
armies and actually heal some of those
wounds yeah like this feels this feels
like a speech by George Washington or
Abraham Lincoln or something and you
look at this it's like okay well how
different are we yeah we all want
beautiful things we all want something
that's nice we all want to be able to
work together we all want our stuff to
be used right and so if we can help heal
that now I'm not optimistic that
all people will use Mojo and they'll
stop using C plus plus like that's not
my goal right but um but if we can heal
some of that I think that'd be pretty
cool yeah and we start by putting the
people who like braces into the gulag no
uh so so there are proposals for adding
braces to Mojo and we just tell what's
your thing we tell them no okay
politely yeah anyway so there's a lot of
amazing features on the roadmap and
those already implemented it it'd be
awesome I could just ask you a few
things yeah so uh the the other
performance Improvement comes from
immutability so what's the what's this
VAR and this let thing that we got going
on well what's immutability
yeah so one of the things that is uh
useful and it's not always required but
it's useful is knowing whether something
can change out from underneath you right
so in Python you have a pointer to an
array right and so you pass that pointer
to an array around to things
if you pass into a function they may
take that and scrolled away in some
other data structure and so you get your
array back and you go to use it now
somebody else is like putting stuff in
your array how do you reason about that
it gets to be very complicated at least
lots of bugs right and so one of the
things that you know again this is not
something Mojo forces on you but
something that Mojo enables is a thing
called value semantics and what value
semantics do is they take
collections like arrays like
dictionaries also tensors and strings
and things like this that are much
higher level and make them behave like
proper values and so it makes it look
like if you pass these things around you
get a logical copy of all the data and
so if I pass you an array it's your
array you can go do what you want to it
you're not going to hurt my array now
that is an interesting and very powerful
design principle it defines away a ton
of bugs you have to be careful to
implement it in an efficient way as
their performance hit that's a
significant
uh generally not if you implement it the
right way but it requires a lot of very
low level uh getting the language right
bits I assume there'll be a huge
performance hit because it's a really
the benefit is really nice because you
don't get into that absolutely well the
trick is is you can't do it you can't do
copies
so you have to provide
the behavior of copying without doing
the copy yeah how do you do that
is that how do you do that it's not
magic it's just it's actually pretty
cool well so first before we talk about
how that works let's talk about how it
works in Python right so in Python you
define a person class or maybe a person
class is a bad idea you define a
database class right and database class
has an array of Records something like
that right and so the problem is that if
you pass in a record or class instance
into the database it'll take a hold of
that object and then it assumes it has
it and if you're passing an object in
you have to know that that database is
going to take take it and therefore you
shouldn't change it after you put in the
database right this is this you kind of
have to know that you just have to kind
of know that right and so you roll out
version one of the database you just
kind of have to know that of course Lex
uses its own database right yeah right
because you built it you understand how
this works right somebody else joins the
team they don't know this yes right and
so now they suddenly get bugs you're
having to maintained the database you
shake your fist you argue the tenth time
this happens you're like okay we have to
do something different right and so what
you do is you go check change your
python code and you change your database
class to copy the record every time you
add it and so what ends up happening is
you say okay I will do what's called a
defensive copy inside the database and
then that way if somebody passes
something in I will have my own copy of
it and they can go do whatever and
they're not going to break my thing
okay this is usually the the two design
patterns if you look in pytorch for
example this is cloning a tensor like
there's a specific thing and you have to
know where to call it if you don't call
in the right place you get these bugs
and this is state of the art right
so a different approach so it's used in
many languages so I've worked with it in
Swift
um is you say okay well let's provide
value semantics and so we want to
provide the view that you get a
logically independent copy but we want
to do that lazily
and so what what we do is you say okay
if you pass something into a function it
doesn't actually make a copy what it
actually does is it just increments a
reference to it and if you pass it
around you stick in your database
it can go in the database you own it
and then you come back out of the stack
nobody's copied anything you come back
out of the stack and then the caller
lets go of it well then you've just
handed it off to the database you've
transferred it and there's no copies
made
now on the other hand if you know your
co-worker goes and hands you a record
and you pass it in you stick it in the
database and then you go to town and you
start modifying it what happens is you
get a copy lazily on demand
and so what this does is gives you
copies only when you need them and it
also so it defines away the bugs but
also generally reduces the number of
copies in practice and so but the
implementation details are tricky here
yeah so this is yes something with
reference Counting
but to make it performant
across a number of different kinds of
objects yeah well so you need a couple
of things and so there's many so this
concept has existed in many different
worlds and so that again it's not novel
research at all right the magic is
getting the design right so that you can
do this in a reasonable way right so
there's a number of components that go
into this one is when you're passing
around so we're talking about Python and
reference counting at the expense of
doing that when you're passing values
around you don't want to do extra
reference counting for no good reason
and so you have to make sure that you're
efficient and you transfer ownership
instead of duplicating references and
things like that which is a very low
level problem you also have to adopt
this and you have to build these data
structures and so if you say you know
Mojo has to be compatible with python so
of course the default list is a
reference semantic list that works the
way you'd expect in Python but then you
have to design a value semantic list
so you just have to implement that and
then you implement the logic within and
so the the role of the language here is
to provide all the low-level hooks that
allow the author of the type to be able
to get and express this Behavior without
forcing it into all cases or hard coding
this into the language itself but
there's uh ownership So you you're
constantly transfer your tracking who
owns the thing yes and so there's a
whole system called ownership and so
this is related to work done in the Rusk
Community also the Swift community's
done a bunch of work and there's a bunch
of different other languages that have
all kind of C plus plus actually has
copy Constructors and destructors and
things like that and so
um and I mean single spell says
everything so it has move Constructors
it has like this whole world of things
and so this is uh this is a body of work
that's kind of been developing for many
many years now and so Mojo takes some of
the best
ideas out of all these systems and
remixes in a nice way so that you get
the power of something like the rust
programming language but you don't have
to deal with it when you don't want to
which is a major thing in terms of
teaching and learning and being able to
use and scale these systems uh how does
that play with argument conventions what
are they why are they important how does
the value semantics how does the
transfer ownership uh work with with the
arguments when they're passing yeah so
so if you go deep into systems
programming land so this isn't again
this is not something for everybody but
if you go deep into systems programming
land what you encounters you encounter
these types that get weird so if you're
used to python you think about
everything I could just copy it around I
can go change it and mutate it and do
these things and it's all cool
um if you get into systems programming
land you get into these things like I
have an atomic number or I have a mutex
or I have a uniquely owned database
handle things like this right so these
types you can't necessarily copy yeah
sometimes you can't necessarily even
move them to a different address
and so what Mojo allows you to do is it
allows you to express hey I don't want
to get a copy of this thing I want to
actually just get a reference to it and
by doing that what you can say is you
can say okay if I'm defining something
weird like a atomic number or something
it's like it has to be so it's an atomic
number is a an area in memory that
multiple threads can access at a time
without synchronous without without
locks right and so uh and so like the
definition of atomic numbers multiple
different things have to be poking it
therefore they have to agree on where it
is right so you can't just like move it
out from underneath one because it kind
of breaks what what it means and so
that's that's an example of a type that
you can't even you can't copy you can't
move it like once you create it has to
be where it was right now if you look at
many other examples like a database
handle right so okay well what happens
how do you copy a database handle do you
copy the whole database that's not
something you necessarily want to do
um the there's a lot of types like that
where you want to be able say that they
are uniquely owned and so there's always
one of this thing and or if if I create
a thing I don't copy it and so what Mojo
allows you to do is it allows you to say
hey I want to pass around a reference to
this thing without copying it and so it
has borrowed conventions so you can say
you can use it but you don't get to
change it you can pass it by mutable
reference and so if you do that then you
can you get a reference to it but you
can change it and so it manages all that
kind of stuff so it's uh it's just a
really nice implementation of like C
plus plus has yeah uh you know the
reference kinds of pointers yeah smart
smart different different kinds of
applications and smart pointers that you
can uh explicitly Define this allows you
but you're saying that's more like
um the weird case versus the common case
well it depends on where I mean I mean I
don't I don't think I'm a normal person
so yes I mean I'm not one to call other
people weird yeah
but the uh uh but you know if you talk
to a normal python a typical python
programmer you're definitely not about
this right this is a lower level of
abstraction now if you talk to a C plus
plus programmer certainly if you talk to
a rust programmer again they're not
weird they're delightful like these are
all good people right
um those those folks will think about
all the time
right and so I look at this as there's a
spectrum between very deep low-level
systems I'm going to go poke the bits
and care about how they're laid out in
memory all the way up to application and
scripting and other things like this and
so it's not that anybody's right or
wrong it's about how do we build
one system that scales
by the way the the idea of an atomic
number has been something that always
brought me deep happiness because
the flip side of that the the idea that
threads can just modify stuff
um
asynchronously it's the whole idea of
concurrent programming is a source of
infinite stress for me well so this is
where you jump into
um you know again you zoom out and get
out of program languages or compilers
and just look what the industry has done
my mind is constantly blown by this
right and you look at what you know
Moore's Law Moore's law has this idea
that like computers for a long time
single thread performance just got
faster and faster and faster and faster
for free but then physics and other
things intervened in power consumption
like other things started to matter and
so what ended up happening is we went
from single Core computers to multi-core
then we went to accelerators right this
this trend towards specialization of
Hardware is only going to continue and
so
for years us programming language nerds
and compiler people have been saying
okay well how do we tackle multi-core
right for a while it was like
multi-course the future we have to get
on top of this thing and then it was
multi-core is the default what are we
doing with this thing and then it's like
there's chips with hundreds of cores in
them what happened right yeah and so
I'm super inspired by the fact that you
know on the face of this you know those
machine learning people invented this
idea of a tensor right and was it tensor
a tensor isn't
like an arithmetic an algebraic concept
it's like an abstraction around a
gigantic paralyzable data set right and
because of that and because of things
like tensorflow and pytorch we're able
to say okay we'll Express the math
of the system this enables you to
automatic differentiations enables you
do like all these cool things
um and and it's it's an abstract
representation well because you have
that abstract representation you can now
map it onto these parallel machines
without having to
um control okay put that by here put
that bite there put that right there and
this has enabled an explosion in terms
of AI compute accelerators like all the
stuff and so that's super super excited